- Hi, I'm Rie.
Today a friend is challenging
me to take a popular food
and make it fancy.
Today's guest is my friend Jeri.
- Hey everyone, it's Jeri.
I am so excited to challenge Rie today.
Are you ready to find out
what the secret ingredient is?
- I am ready.
- [Jeri] Let's bring it in.
- Let's see what I'm making fancy today.
- [Jeri] Okay.
(drum rolls)
- [Rie] Lay's, but Magic Masala?
- This India's Magic Masala potato chips
are a super popular snack in India.
In fact, in 2012 they were
the most favorited flavor
in India.
- Let's try this.
I can see this became number one.
It's not too spicy, but
heat is definitely there.
There is like a hint of tanginess.
I already know there was a mango.
There is a tomato powder.
Great choice.
- Okay, so you're up for the challenge?
- Mm-hmm.
- Well, before we wrap up,
I have one more challenge for you.
So I brought this cookbook for you.
You're going to open
it up to a random page,
and whatever the main
ingredient is in the recipe
you have to include it in the dish.
- I kind of knew something was up.
- Like I had to throw a little
something else in there, so.
- I hope I don't choose anything strange.
- Let's see where you end up.
What does it say?
- Provencal slow-roasted leg of lamb.
Leg of lamb is pretty fancy.
I have to think how I can incorporate.
- I'm gonna leave it to you.
You're the professional and
you can make anything fancy.
So I feel like you've got this.
- I will try to-
- [Both] Make it fancy.
- All right, here's what I got.
Bread, shallots, limes, mint, potatoes,
Greek yogurt, leaks, garlic, cilantro,
parsley, thyme, Thai
chilis, rosemary, and lamb.
From the pantry I got five
spice powder, garam masala,
cumin seed, club soda, coconut
sugar, olive oil, and MSG.
All right, let's get started.
Make it fancy.
First I'm going to process this.
I just wanna eat it.
It smells good.
And I'm going to keep quarter cup,
and I'm going to use this for later.
And the rest of the powder,
I'm going to use at the next step.
So I have some olive oil heat in the pan,
and here I have cubed bread
and I'm going to toast
bread until golden brown.
And then I'm going to put leftover oil,
add onion, leaks, and just
sprinkle a little bit salt
'cause it's also help cooking faster.
Leaks and onion get a little bit softer,
so I'm going to add garlic now.
Garlic tend to be burnt easily.
So if you have bunch of ingredients
you should add that first and then garlic.
Smells good and looking good,
so I'm going to add Lay's
India's Magic Masala
potato chip powder.
The onions are translucent
and leaks are soft,
and I'm going to add back toasted bread
and incorporate it together.
All right, looking good.
And I'm gonna take this off from the heat
and add more flavors.
Okay, and I'm gonna add
lime juice and lime zest.
Lime zest has a lot of good flavor
that the juice doesn't have.
And we have garam masala,
adding mint and parsley,
and I'm gonna add salt.
This, it's gonna be flavor explosion.
It's spicy but it's good spicy.
Little bit more salt.
Sometimes when I eat too spicy food
I feel like my ears are gonna fall off,
but this one doesn't have that.
The bread is still a little bit dry,
so I want to put it in a refrigerator
so everything gonna soak
up all the goodness.
So I'm going to cover this
and I'm going to rest this
in the refrigerator about 30 minutes.
So this step I will need
my little surgery gloves.
Leg of lamb.
And another Tasty hack,
if you don't have dedicated
cutting board for meat
you can just wrap with plastic,
so it doesn't cross-contaminate.
You want to use flat part of meat pounder
and you want to pound
meat and kind of smear.
The reason you want to pound
meat is to tenderize the meat
and also you want to
make it even thickness.
It's gonna take a little time
and I'm gonna pound this
a little more flatter,
but before that, let's get fancy.
(soft piano)
(upbeat rock music)
All right, I finish pounding
the meat and trimmed the meat
because it was a little too big.
Now, I'm going to stuff this lamb.
I'm going to put here and
I'm going to roll this over.
This part is a little
thin, so I'm going to trim
just because I want to
make sure it cook evenly.
We are going to cook this together
and I'm going to score just a little bit,
so the seasoning kind
of get into the meat.
It's like diagonal and just
season surface of the meat
with salt and pepper.
And I'm going to use butcher twine.
And make sure to use butcher twine
because if you use other kind of string,
it might burn in oven.
You can find butcher
twine in a grocery store.
And I'm going to tie this meat
because it's kind of rolled up,
and if you don't tie it,
it's gonna fall apart.
Kind of make L shape.
When you tie with butcher twine,
you don't wanna tie too tight
because while it's cooking
it's kind of like steam
and expand and shrink.
Purpose of tying is just hold the shape.
All right, and this is done,
and I'm going to cut extra string.
Move it to sheet pan
with cooling rack on top.
Beautiful.
I'm going to bake this at 350 oven
until the internal
temperature reaches 145.
Let's cook some potatoes.
I'm using Yukon Gold.
This potato it's the good
potato to make a roasted potato
'cause it holds its shape.
And I have one more Tasty hack.
You can use heel and
remove eyes of potato.
And I have two chopsticks
and you are gonna just slice.
So chopsticks is the guide,
so you don't accidentally cut through.
You see it's the hasselback
potato, it's the way of cutting.
So I'm keeping potatoes in water
because it washes our extra starch.
Potato oxidizes so you
want to keep in water.
All right, all potatoes are hasselbacked,
and we are moving onto next step.
I want to eat these chips.
So I have a stick of butter.
It looks like there are too much butter,
but there's not such a thing.
Add garam masala, black pepper, and salt.
Give a light stir and add
Lay's India's Magic Masala,
and you want to cook potato
chips until it's get softened.
I think Lay's India's Magic
Masala chips is too long,
so let's call it Lay's Magic Chips.
Smells so good.
If you come close to the
screen, I think you can smell.
I'm going to sprinkle this magic butter.
Did you hear that?
Okay, I'm gonna toss.
I did a hasselback cut
because it will trap the
all good butter and spice.
My lamb is almost ready
and it's a good time
to put this potato along with lamb.
It will take about 30 minutes.
So this is a leftover potato chips.
I bet this is gonna be so good
'cause it's soaked in butter,
so let me try.
Hot potato chips, so good.
I think I want to
incorporate this into my dish
or I'm gonna just eat them all.
So good.
So we have Lay's Magic Chips
and toasted cumin seeds
and coconut sugar,
and I'm gonna just make it into powder,
and then add yogurt.
Thai chili, I think it's a a lot.
So my spicy tolerance is not that high,
so I'm gonna just use half.
I'm gonna add the lime
juice, add all the salt.
Right, and I'm going to process.
And I'm adding fresh herbs.
I'm adding last.
When you put fresh herbs in the beginning,
the processor, the heat kind
of turns those kind of brown.
The herbs is very fresh,
so we want to make the sauce
a little bit light and bright.
It's still a little chunky,
so I'm going to add water
'cause I want to make it like a sauce.
Looking good and smells good.
This is my spicy herb yogurt sauce.
Mm.
Oh, spicy.
This is a little spicy, but
definitely compliments my dish.
I think Jeri would love it.
Right, I have my flour.
I'm adding Chinese five
spice, garam masala, and MSG.
I think MSG is a little bit
controversial ingredient,
but it's basically just a umami booster,
and black pepper, salt.
Whisk so all the spices
is evenly distributed.
Add quarter cup of ground
magic chips I saved earlier
and club soda.
All right, so I have batter
I just made right here,
and I'm going to dip sliced
shallot, drop in oil.
I'm going to finish frying
them and finally assemble.
Right, so this was baked and rested,
and I'm going to remove twine first.
I'm glad how it turns out.
It is still holding the
shape because of the twine.
I'm gonna give us some slice.
I'm going to put spicy herb
yogurt sauce on the bottom.
Put this on top.
Jeri has this food Instagram,
it looks so polished so I want
to make sure to impress her.
And we are done.
(bright uplifting music)
Lay's India's Magic
Masala spiced leg of lamb
and hasselback potato.
The longest dish name,
but still very fancy.
All right, let's bring out
our special guest, Jeri.
- [Both] Yay.
- How are you?
- [Rie] I'm good.
- I'm pretty, I'm pretty ready for this.
- Do you wanna open?
- Yes, okay.
Big reveal.
- Ta-da.
- Wow.
- [Rie] So.
- Wait, what's happening?
- Oh, okay, a feast.
- Yeah.
I made stuffing with magic
chips, spicy herb yogurt sauce,
and hasselback potatoes with
magic chips infused butter.
- You're amazing.
I'm like trying to keep up with you.
This looks incredible.
I wish you could all smell this.
Okay, let's do it.
Look at that bite.
That's gonna be it.
- Not very, it's spicy.
- That is incredible.
- Yay.
I made the right call.
There was small ramekin
full of Thai chili.
- Ooh.
- And I'm like,
"This might too spicy."
- How many did you put in there?
I can handle it.
I can handle it, but it's a little spicy.
I love potatoes.
If anyone knows me, I love potatoes.
I love a good sauce,
so this is like my kryptonite right here.
Everything from the five
spice to the garam masala,
and that subtle sweetness
from the cinnamon?
Honestly, I can go scoop after scoop.
This is really good.
- Yay.
Jeri, did I make Lay's
India's Magic Masala fancy?
- You killed it.
You made it fancy and
went above and beyond.
This is amazing.
Let me go in.
Let me try this.
- This is so good.
- I am not kidding when I
say that the taste of this
is identical to the flavors on this plate.
The make it fancy queen.
- We have one last thing to do.
Three, two, one.
- [Both] Make it fancy.
- Can I take it now?
- Yes.
- Yes, absolutely.
(lively upbeat music)